in Hollywood humanlike robots can do
just about anything in the real world
though these Bots struggle to do simple
tasks that humans do easily for years
scientists have tried to overcome these
limitations the goal is to reliably use
robots in the rubble of disasters
finally scientists robotic Creations are
starting to become more reliable as
search and rescue
operators one of these Bots called
robosimian ditches some aspects of being
humanoid altogether
it can crawl and roll and has mechanized
fingers specifically designed for
gripping and manipulating
objects another bot takes a Terminator
like look and has already mastered
several tricky tasks such as opening
doors and picking up tools used to punch
through
walls these tasks and others are part of
darpa's Robotics challenge which is
driving Research into robots that can
operate in disaster
zones the finals of this competition
slated for the summer of 2015 and it's
here that the Bots will have to master
several tasks in just an
hour the best bot and its operators take
home a $2 million prize and they will
definitely have an excuse for
showboating at the end of the
day